[Music]
[Applause]
he's the man of the hour he's Greg Olsen
Fox NFL analyst for the second straight
year to journo is giving fans a chance
to win free pizza the kicker dinks at
any point in the Super Bowl Uh Kevin and
Greg will team up with dejo to celebrate
the all proo combo of pizza and football
and discuss the big games unpredictable
out out comes and uh for more on this
special discounts uh to enter for a
chance to win go to Douro
ds.com Greg olssen joining us on the
program Greg good to have you back uh
let me go back to the fourth down call
by the Lions and you said they disguised
their coverage the Niners disguised
their coverage on Jared gof when do you
realize this and how that's going to
affect the play and what you're going to
say on
TV
yeah so what happened was so what a lot
of teams do is they use their backs to
their tight ends and they put them in
unconventional formations where maybe
they're outside the receiver they're in
the slot and they they want to get tells
so what happened there early and we came
back and showed the replay is Dre
Greenlaw was walked on jir Gibbs he was
he was the furthest receiver out to the
right so that was The Mantel for Jared
gof so you see gof he brings Gibbs in
from being out wide to put him back in
the backfield next to him in the gun and
then gof gives the hand signal or the
check or whatever the play is going to
be so you'll see green law comes back in
with them so it looks again that's a
Manel you know a lot of the times and
give credit to San Francisco and wils
they ended up just zoning it out they
ended up just shelling it out and
they're running mesh you know which is
like guys Crossing each other like
running shallow drags trying to run
interference and run their mans and you
know run their man coverage into each
other and um they were running a man
type concept against what ended up
looking like man but playing like Zone
and that's why G had nowhere to go early
he tried to flush and get it late down
the field to Aman R st Brown and was
just off balance and didn't get enough
on it so those are critical moments in
the game right that's the chess match
back and forth pre-nap tells post Snap
tells um and in that critical moment
they San Francisco got the stop they
needed yeah and you did a great job in
seeing it and saying it because you got
to do it quickly play happens now what
happened do you watch on the monitor or
do you watch onto the
field yeah so my process is so I have
two monitors so I have my telestrator
which is like the production that's what
everyone sees on their TV at home right
that's I have no bearing on that that
just is just a copy of whatever is being
broadcast into you know into the homes I
have a sky cam which is like you know
the cable cam behind the quarterback so
I have that monitor and then I have an
all 202 but those are all on delays so
they're on about a 4se second delay from
what's actually happening on the field
so so I watch it live on the field which
in essence is like an all 22 like you
know from above and then I see it and
then by the time Kevin is done with his
call I can then either go to the all 22
or the sky based on what I want to see
and then I can either confirm I can
finalize numbers get my make sure what I
saw live is actually what I see and then
by the time it's on my telestrator by
the time it's you know Kevin is done and
I got to jump in to talk I have a pretty
good sense I saw it live I saw it on a
quick little 4-second delay
so I'm pretty certain that what I'm
going to say is what happened and
doesn't always play out that way but
that's the me you know that's the method
that I've developed in the booth the
last couple years and and it's helped me
just make sure what I say I'm confident
is what really happened and players will
talk about the game slows down when you
play the game like after a couple of
years you eventually see it differently
quarterbacks talk about it it slows down
a little bit as a
broadcaster did it slow down for you
where it be became
easier oh absolutely you know the my my
first year I I think I I always joke now
with with our with our producer um Z I
always say like I'm when I first started
doing this I only had like a couple
camera angles and it was probably for
the best you know they probably had more
they just didn't want to overwhelm me so
my replays were you know behind the
defense behind the offense every once in
a while in all 22 like from above or
just like an ISO shot it's just all
right it's going to be on you know CD
lamb or it's going to be on whoever that
was it and I would just do my
telestrations and do my but then when I
as I kept going I realized oh my God
there's a million more cameras and you
just get more comfortable you get more
fluid hey whatever they throw up on the
telestrator it's not going to catch me
off guard anymore but you watching the
plays unfold on the field was always
very natural to me I'll tell you the
biggest transition Dan that I had was
for my whole career watching game film I
would always watch it from behind the
offense so that was my perspective of
seeing NFL football
forever and now we sometimes do it from
behind the defense they call it pit or
you do it from like a a corner sideline
where so you want to talk about the left
guard but now you're doing it from
behind the defense so he's actually on
the right and you know so like little
things like that I had to like retrain
my brain that okay for 14 years you
watched film like this well this isn't
film this is live television and we're
not going to just show the same camera
angle for three hours every weekend so
little things like that you get better
at and uh you know my my team spent a
lot of time with me helping me progress
through a lot of those things early on
let's look at the Lions calls with h
fourth down um did you agree with the
calls and the plays that were called
because they you sometimes you can call
the right play but it doesn't turn out
well but I'm curious from your
perspective now three days later did
they make the right calls on those
fourth down
yeah so first and foremost I think going
for it was the right move for for
multiple reasons and I know this has
been like the hot button topic now since
the game ended and we said it very early
in the game right there's there's a way
to be aggressive in the NFL there's two
ways you can be aggressive in your play
calling which we didn't think was what
they were going to do I don't think
Detroit wanted to come out and throw the
ball 50 times and throw it downfield and
hold the ball and let that rush and I
think that plays into the teeth of this
San Francisco defense so they ran the
ball we said hey lean on your run game
run the ball run the ball and and they
did in the first half especially but you
can be aggressive in your game in your
game strategy in your game management
right and that's where Dan Campbell has
no one's run more fake punts no one's
converted more no one's attempted more
fourth Downs or converted more that's
been his style since he took over three
years ago trying to build this winning
culture there so when you're in a game
like that against San Francisco the best
part of your team if you're Detroit is
your offense so if if you're going to
put the burden if it's a coin flip
decision or it's a I if I'm Dan Campbell
I don't blame him for always putting the
load on his offense it's the best unit
of the team they scored 31 points and
lost yeah the notion that more
conservative game management was the
answer to score more points that's just
not how the NFL works so the notion of
hey just take the
points there's no take the points on 48
yard field goals these are not gimme
chip shots so I think that's where
people lose it's like hey 48 yard or
just tie the game up well last year in
the Super Bowl we watched Harrison
Buckner on Fourth and three in the first
quarter hey San Francisco it's 7 s just
I mean uh Kansas City go take the lead
early get the lead and he doed it off
the left crossbar he's the best kicker
in the league they thought they were
taking the points on Fourth and
three and the score so like that's the
narrative we have to stop when the
kicker misses it it's the kicker when
they go for it and they don't make it
it's the coach we're talking to Greg
Olen NFL on Fox analyst joining us
courtesy of Douro for more on what he's
doing Douro
ds.com uh since you played the position
how would you defend Travis Kelce if
you're the 49ers whether it's their
safety or their linebackers what does he
do and how do you stop what he's doing
from your perspective
man it's it's hard you know what he's
doing is unprecedented and you know I've
been on record calling his games and set
it on broadcast and it I think we're
starting I never thought anyone would
ever catch Tony Gonzalez from a
production standpoint from a lang
longevity of his career and what he was
able to do was was pretty remarkable
when you saw Tony compared to the you
know two three four guys as far as
production and what he was able to
accomplish over a long time I think
Kelsey's either arrived already or he's
nipping at his heels because he should
have had 8,000 yard seasons in a row he
didn't play in the last game I think he
needed like 15 yards so in essence he
was GNA get it it wasn't that big of a
deal to him his Playoff records I mean
when you're breaking Jerry Rice's
records you're entering a new
Stratosphere of production in the
postseason but as far as stopping him I
don't I don't know if you're ever going
to like completely shut him down I I do
think the challenge of Kelsey is he's
not running conventional routes that you
can really prepare for it's not hey he's
going to run 14 yards and hook a left
and he's going to catch this ball two
yards outside the hash mark So on your
Zone drops drop there right you're not
because if you drop there he's gonna
stop his route and end somewhere else
like he's playing improv in the moment
real time decision route running and
momes sees it the exact same way so it's
very hard so I how I would defend him I
think you got to get on him I think the
more space he has to run and weave and
find fi
him and Mahomes are just playing at a
different level than maybe anybody ever
so I think you got to get on them I
think you got to reroute them I think
you've got to be at the line of
scrimmage getting them with people
behind you to help I I don't think this
is like hey one zone coverage one
concept one player this is a group
effort and you have to be really good in
critical Downs because when it matters
the most Mahomes is throwing him the
ball so you better have an answer for
him and very few teams have given your
situation uh at Fox now as a broadcaster
what do you want to do moving
forward I want to call top games you
know and I I I feel you know two years
ago when when everything unfolded and
you know obviously I've known Tom was
coming for you know over you know two
years year and a half whatever you want
to call it and uh you know that part of
it we always knew it was a matter of
when we didn't know exactly when the
timeline you ended up not coming this
past season which gave me a second year
with Kevin in the booth with the A Team
but you know going forward my my goals
haven't changed you know my goals when I
started out calling games with Fox you
know three years ago was I aspired to be
a top broadcaster I really thought I
could do it I thought if given the
opportunity and the chance I could show
people that I could do it and I got the
opportunity and fox was kind enough to
give me that and I think over the last
two years we've really changed the
narrative I think we've changed where
hey this is just a placeholder this is a
guy to being like no this this guy can
do it so my my goals and aspirations if
anything have even gotten more committed
to I want to call top games I want to
call games in front of 57 million people
and and dive into the biggest moments
and why it's happening and I feel like
we've done as good a job as that as
anybody in the industry over the last
couple seasons and where that is how
that is when that is I don't know right
there's so many moving Parts out of my
control but my goal is to be a top a
broadcaster again and I'm going to do
everything in my power to achieve that
and um that's been the the goal that
I've laid out since I entered this field
upon retirement three years ago would
you ask for a
trade we're I'm not really in the
business of making demands you know I'm
not sitting here holding anyone's feet
to the fire fox understands the position
I'm in they understand what my
aspirations are um and you know we're
not sitting there banging the table and
saying we you have to let us you know I
we're not in that we're not doing that
you know we we understand what we signed
up for uh they understand where where I
am and being at this stage of my career
of where I want to go and I think we're
all we understand the delicate situation
that we're in right I I I understand
when Tom Brady's looming over your
shoulder it's the biggest news in sports
I get it he's Tom Brady he's someone
I've respected for damn 20 years um so I
I I understand the the uniqueness of
what's going on and I feel like we've
handled it as well as we could for the
last two years and if I can get another
opportunity to call top games at Fox or
somewhere else we'll we'll cross that
bridge when we get there if I put you
and Brady in the octagon and the winner
gets to call the top games on
Fox that'd be quite that'd be quite the
pay-per-view I think Tom stays in better
shape I think he he works out more than
I have uh I'm my my men's tennis my
men's tennis clinics on Wednesday nights
I don't think uh I don't think had me
quite in fighting shape and I'm not I'm
not fighting Tom Brady that that's a
losing battle uh you're probably not
going to win uh give me the plug that
you and Kevin are working on uh Before
We Say Goodbye well you we talked about
earlier with the dink from last year so
again for the second year djo's got this
fun program where if one of the kickers
DS the ball you know so for those who
don't know dink is like the ball hits
the upright the crossbar and makes you
know makes the dink noise which there
was one last year the Chiefs kicker
Harrison Buckner um which again was
fourth and three and he DED it so we you
can leave that there um if you register
you go to joural dinks register uh you
enter if there's a dink in the Super
Bowl you get a chance to win free pizza
and football the Super Bowl win free
pizza it's a win for everybody but the
kicker I guess you did a great job and
you're doing a great job answering these
questions I know that you're getting the
same ones over and over and everybody
thinks there's going to be a different
answer so uh good luck with this and uh
there's no shame in if you're calling
you know the second best game on Fox
yeah I mean you you're you're still
doing it for a living and that's really
important but wanting to be better
greater that's the important part uh you
know that game should not mean less
because it's not as important as you
know that the Marquee game so good luck
with that as you move forward and you
and Kevin certainly made a wonderful
team thank you Greg I appreciate it
thanks for having me that's Greg Olsen
NFL and fox analyst former tight end
went to three Pro bowls and uh first
round pick by the Panthers